[Musik]
leute was wieder platz willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich habe gerade zwei gäste bei mir
einmal robin und mag ich habe mark hat
schon einen kleinen streich gespielt
weil das ganze wahrscheinlich am
bildschirm gelesen es geht heute um das
iphone iks braucht auf jeden fall
folgendes wir haben uns jeder
eingestellt also wir mit insgesamt drei
bestellt die sind alle hier zu mir
gekommen weil die beiden in der heimat
war nicht bald in köln und was jetzt
halt gerade ein bisschen blöd ist wir
haben jetzt bis jetzt zwei schon da aber
die sind schon relativ also das kann
leicht passieren dass irgendwie
verspätet kommen also und eins fehlt
auch problem ist nur dieser stelle wir
sind drei- und einen kann halt dann muss
halt drauf verzichten
ich habe mir jetzt einfach überlegt also
das video wird auf jeden fall nicht auch
wenn nicht aber es wird krass wir machen
jetzt einfach schlecht schnitt bis 3 und
das 2
warum ist man nicht über mein iphone hat
so etwas nicht auch google hat die leute
ich zeige euch mal kurz das hier ist
einmal das iphone iks das mag jetzt nach
wie dass wir zwei stunden ausgepackt hat
also sieht auf jeden fall mega stylische
aus dass kur ist der display ist
komplett über das ganze hier war das
zweite mal 11 ja und wer das jetzt
mitnehmen darf und nicht länger darauf
warten muss man zeigt uns doch mal was
es geht
[Musik]
xfx danken der alex dass es hier
hergestellt
[Musik]
so leute das iphone liegt in der mitte
ich bin als strich stand bis 3 und der
gewinner freut sich wahrscheinlich sehr
und der verlierer hat hart reingepackt
okay du hast du wirklich bist aber wenn
es 2 2 steht es 4 1 endstand
ich hatte noch nie bei einem stripclub
so viel punkte
bald gehörst du mir war
bis 02 30 wer schon echt krass gewesen
ich mache einfach immer die augen zu
damit es gar nicht anders geht es hier
jetzt spiel gemacht solche regel noch
nichts sonst nur zwei euro
wenn es jetzt aber gleich drei reiche
hierzu nicht aus
doch kommt jetzt schnell löschen
[Musik]
hier wird wieder aus dem cockpit kommt
nix und erstmalig den scheitelpunkt
[Musik]
contento gegeben was ich mit meinen
sachen nachkommen was erstens ganz
bewusst auch nicht halt dazu gehört die
kings jetzt auch 6 4 6 4
insgesamt also ich hab meine form ich
habe bei meinem neuen versenden wir die
kopfhaut die kopfhörer braucht nicht
erst einmal gestartet
jetzt auch genau wann kommt das nächste
in solch und weiß ich kann nicht aber
müsste jetzt auch bekommen also so lange
warst du nicht mehr warten wenn du mich
noch wenn du glück hast richtig bescheid
wenn es einfach okay leute das war's mit
dem kurzen video schaut was hat das
gefallen ich habe jetzt ein neues handy
und ganz wichtig schaut auf jeden fall
bei markt vorbei und habe ich nicht
wirklich hart getränkt erster linie in
der beschreibung kritiker 6 ab einfach
nichts bringt wir sind es morgen wieder
neues video
freut euch auf den dezember gab es jeden
tag video übrigens kassen